bonsoir tout cas cette phrase lancée par
paul mec incliné sur l'imposante scène
des plaines d'abraham le 20 juillet 2008
a immédiatement enflammé des milliers de
personnes venues voir et entendre l'ex
beatle
[Musique]
m
l'ancien directeur général de la société
des fêtes du 400e de québec se souvient
de cette soirée comme d'une véritable
communion
car je pensais cette soirée-là cet
événement alors je pense que c'est
probablement là où une des plus grande
communion artistique jamais présenté
jamais jamais produit ici ceux dans la
région de la capitale pour plusieurs
raisons la première est évidemment parce
que le show eu lieu parceque pas
mécaniste est pas produit très peu dans
les dix années précédentes
d'abord que ce terrain s'ils étaient
pleins à pleine capacité qu'on avait
installé des écrans peu partout sur
grande allée
backstage ali vie et en plus on était en
location de vidéos
ce soir là où on a eu un record de
location de 72000 location de
téléchargement de chou en direct le soir
sauf en sorte qu'on a réuni autour de
cet événement à la 253,5 près de 350
mille personnes qui en même temps ont
vécu la même chose et ont vécu un moment
extraordinaire
[Musique]
de la main l'argent j'ai vu de ma vie ça
valait l'attenté magique de toute ma vie
c'est le plus beau spectacle j'ai eu ce
report a livré un spectacle de 2h30
pendant lequel il a enchaîné des succès
de l'époque des beatles et du groupe de
wings
[Musique]
vêtu d'un manteau avec l'inscription
québec il s'est adressé à la foule en
français et a même brandi le fleurdelisé
probablement une réponse à la polémique
à saveur identitaire qui avait précédé
sa venue celui qui avait fait
contreverse avant le spectacle a
finalement fait l'unanimité sébastien
fans de musique se souvient avec bonheur
de l'événement c'est le plus gros
spectacle que j'ai auquel j'ai assisté
l'effervescence là le côté unique aussi
de la chose d'être un des seuls
spectacles mokrani faisait cette année
l'eau j'étais juste à côté des canons de
feu d'artifice j'ai vu le cerf
incroyable maire de mongla cette
excitation là ce privilège que j'avais
aussi d'être l'eau en même temps c'était
c'était surréel avec le passage de
meknes la ville de québec n'avait jamais
autant été sous les projecteurs
j'ai vu quelque chose de merveilleux qui
vont marquer des générations parce que
tout le monde vous parler de ce ça va
être intéressant parce que dans quoi 20
30 ans il y aura peut-être encore un
grand événement qu'on va présenter à
québec il ya beaucoup de monde qui ont
levé la main que vont dire désolé les
amis mais j'avais vu par mes carnets sur
les plaines mois
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
quand le show était terminée les gens se
sont sont partis dans les rues les gens
chanter des chansons de mes carnets et
monde s'en aller lentement
tranquillement comme si tout le monde
flottant
[Musique]
eh oui douze ans après on se dit
toujours que c'était un spectacle
grandiose dont on va se souvenir encore
longtemps ici que des jeunes elle radio
canada québec